a full trailer of the game actually
leaked all the way back in 2018 when
reddit user vape this bro posted it
online he claimed to have been part of a
mall survey group that was shown a
trailer for the game and he somehow
managed to get by without signing an nda
the leaked footage showed what appeared
to be a dark mature wizarding world game
with one particular scene that showed a
group of goblins meeting a rather
gruesome fate specific spells were also
shown in that trailer including lumos
alohomora repairo stupefy expulso and
depulso it's also worth noting that even
though it's pretty clear this was a
legit leak it still doesn't mean we'll
actually see all of those items in the
final game hogwarts legacy was finally
announced in an official capacity with a
trailer at the ps5 showcase event back
in september of 2020. the game was
originally slated for a 2021 release
date but has since been delayed to the
ever nebulous 2022